le dernier module je vais aujourd'hui
donc vous parler d'une méthode qui
s'appelle le bilan carbone ou plus
exactement de la comptabilité carbone au
sens large en essayant de vous expliquer
pourquoi pour tous les problèmes que
nous avons évoquées jusqu'à maintenant
ça pouvait avoir un sens de compter de
cette manière là alors je sais pas si
vous avez eu ou si vous aurez des cours
d'économie dans le cadre de votre cursus
mais je peux déjà vous expliquez que
vous pouvez les jeter à la poubelle
avant d'avoir ouvert parce qu'il ya
toutes les chances que l'économie qu'on
vous apprennent ou qu'on vous ait appris
dans le cadre de vos études parts de
cette relation que vous connaissez peut
être déjà qui est que la production est
une fonction du capital et du travail
en tout cas c'est comme ça que
l'économie classique a été théorisée il
ya deux siècles et c'est toujours sur
cette économie là que nous fonctionnons
aujourd'hui quand il s'agit de faire de
la macro ou de la microéconomie vous
voyez je me suis pas concertées avec les
échos le pas plus tard que ce matin il
ya une interview d'un du dirigeant de
suez environnement et qui explique
exactement ce que je vais vous raconter
dans très exactement 15 secondes il dit
nous avons été élevés dans l'idée que
l'économie et l'optimisation de deux
grands facteurs le capital et le travail
le 21e siècle nous contraindre à
optimiser l'usagé des matières premières
donc en fait cet homme dit très
exactement ceci ça marche pas c'est pas
vrai c'est une bonne approximation au
premier ordre dans un univers infini
mais dans un monde fini c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut compter dans un monde fini
il faut considérer que la production est
une fonction du travail humain bien
évidemment du capital humain bien
évidemment mais aussi des ressources
naturelles il est évident que sans
ressources naturelles
il n'y a pas de système socio-économique
qui tiennent debout le stylo avec lequel
vous êtes en train d'écrire sans minerai
de fer et en charbon et bien on ne fait
pas la plume les lunettes que vous
portez sans sable et sans énergie pour
les avoir fabriqués elle n'existe pas
les vêtements que vous portez pas plus
le bon sur lequel vous êtes assis pas
plus et ses oeufs dans un monde dans
lequel il n'y aurait pas inconscient
d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère vous seriez
tout simplement pas assez
bon donc la production est à l'évidence
une fonction du capital du travail et
des ressources naturelles et d'une
aptitude à profiter de l'environnement
il se trouve que les deux derniers
éléments que je viens de citer n'ont pas
eu de contreparties économiques dans
l'économie classique
c'était même pu briser comme ça un des
économistes classiques célèbres qui
s'appelle jean baptiste say disait que
les ressources naturelles étaient
inépuisables et qu'elle n'avait pas de
prix qu'elle n'était pas rare et donc
elle n'était pas l'objet de la science
économique s'est explicitement écrit
dans les yeux cours d'économie classique
alors comme vous le savez considérer que
deltastock nuls tant que le stock est
infini c'est une bonne approximation on
peut considérer que c'est une
approximation valable quand le stock
cesse d'être infiniment deltastock est
pas nul donc il faut en tenir compte
cela veut dire que ça veut dire que
l'économie que nous avons connu jusqu'à
maintenant encore une fois est une
économie qui n'est pas adapté un monde
dans lequel vous allez passer
l'essentiel de votre vie professionnelle
c'est à dire un monde dans lequel comme
l'habit ce patron de suez environnement
et il ya des tas de gens qui disent
exactement la même chose aujourd'hui
il va falloir de plus en plus tenir
compte de ce qu'on n'a jamais compté
jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire une
forme de dotations aux avertissements à
la consommation d'un bien qui s'amortit
pour tout ce qui n'est pas renouvelable
est une forme de provisions pour risques
c'est d'ailleurs le fait de mettre
d'ores et déjà dans ses comptes
quelque chose une charge future à
quelque chose qu'on va devoir payer plus
tard pour perturbation différé de
l'environnement notamment le changement
climatique qui va vous coûter alors que
vous n'aurez pas été à l'origine des
émissions ça veut donc dire cette
affaire que vous ne pouvez pas voir
venir avec l'économie classique une
partie des problèmes qui sont pourtant
des problèmes économiques que nous
allons devoir gérer plus tard en clair
comme ya un certain nombre de flux
physiques ceux sur lesquels on a passé
beaucoup de temps pendant les 7 offre
les sept modules de cours qui viennent
de s'écouler qui ne sont pas dans la
manière actuelle de penser l'économie
eh bien il faut repartir de plus bas il
faut répartir de l'état
physique pour être capable de voir venir
le problème en d'autres termes les
problèmes physiques qu'on a évoqué si
vous ne repartez pas de la physique
c'est plus économique qui vous montrera
qu'ils sont là avant que vous ayez à
faire les conséquences au moment où
l'économie montrera des problèmes sont
là vous serez très avancé dans la
manifestation de problème et c'est
malgré vos brillantes servette
d'ingénieur à ce moment là on pourra
plus faire grand chose pour éviter une
partie des conséquences désagréables
donc dubé c'est que vous devez repartir
de la physique et c'est très exactement
l'esprit du bilan carbone ou de la
comptabilité carbone d'une manière
générale la comptabilité carbone l
invocation à se mettre très exactement
sur ce flux la dont je vous rappelle
encore une fois qu'il est à l'origine de
la quasi totalité de ce que nous avons
vécu pendant ou qu'il a contribué plus
exactement à la quasi totalité de ce que
nous avons vécu comment 20e siècle et
c'est donc une manière de plain pied qui
permet à la fois d'avoir de la
visibilité sur l'aspect émission c'est à
dire de se confronter à la contrainte
quand on parle de changement climatique
mais aussi d'avoir de la visibilité sur
un des aspects ressources très important
en tout cas très important dans quatre
de secours ce qui est déjà suffisant
c'est à dire la question de l'énergie
fossile et donc de se confronter à la
contrainte sur sur laquelle va aussi
normalement à ce stade vous avez un
aperçu à peu près correct il y a déjà
des inventeurs des missions vous allez
voir que le bilan carbone d'un
inventaire des missions particuliers qui
sont obligatoires il y en a un en
particulier qui l'est c'est celui que
tous les pays doivent faire dans le
cadre de la convention climat dont je
vous rappelle que l'acronyme anglo-saxon
est une fcc série united nations
framework convention on climate
challenge
voilà il va falloir que vous apprenez sa
part que la marche blanche donc dans le
cadre de la convention qui marque les
ou qui ont ratifié cette convention il
s'agit pas du protocole de kyoto il
s'agit bien de la convention climat ont
l'obligation de publier des inventaires
d'édition alors c'est d'inventaires
d'émissions
ils sont faits comment ils prennent en
compte toutes les sources qui sont
présentes sur un territoire donné
donc si je fait l'inventaire des
missions de la france je vais prendre en
compte tout ce qui se passe en france et
rien qu'en france donc j'ai une
chaudière en france
j'en tiens compte j'ai une voiture qui
circule sans sortir de france jean piat
compte j'ai une vache qui rôdent du
métal en france j'en tiens compte j'ai
une décharge qui émettent du méthane en
france j'en tiens compte j'ai un champ
sur lequel j'ai mis des engrais azotés
et qui m'aimait du protoxyde d'azoté
j'en tiens compte par contre vous
acheter une machine à laver qui a été
fabriqué ap wan hé bien je ne tiens pas
compte dans cet inventaire l'un de
l'émission de la chaudière taïwanaise
qui a été nécessaire pour travailler
l'acier et je ne tiens pas compte de la
raffinerie ou qu'elle soit qui a permis
de fabriquer le naphta avec lequel on a
fait le plastique qui sera contenue dans
votre machine à laver
donc c'est un inventaire tout la seule
règle d'attribution et le fait que la
source soit directement situées sur le
territoire
c'est un inventaire qui se lit vite si
l'on peut dire à silvia à effet de serre
qui sont compris afin qu'ils sont
réclamées par le protocole de kyoto qui
sont le co2 donc le dioxyde de carbone
le méthane
excusez moi il ya une très belle erreur
c'est pas une marque assez ch4
évidemment enzo le protoxyde d azote et
trois familles dalo quelque chose de
familles dalo carbure et un halo
sulfures qui est le sf6 il n'y a pas
dans ces inventaires d'émissions milo
zones qui sont là gaz à effet de serre
ni l'avatar but stratosphérique qui joue
également un rôle dans le
énergie sur la surface de la planète et
l'espace comme je vous le disais donc
ces inventaires sont obligatoires dans
le cadre de la convention climat et
enfin si ils sont strictement limitées
aux sources présentes sur le territoire
vous avez quand même le droit d'enlever
un petit quelque chose
si vous investissez de l'argent dans un
autre pays enfin ça c'est dans le cadre
du protocole de kyoto dans un autre pays
qui a des obligations ou qu'il n'y en a
pas ça dépend du mécanisme qui est mise
en jeu
vous avez le droit de déduire un petit
quelque chose de votre propre inventaire
national mais on veut ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que c'est essentiellement
quelque chose qui est limité à ce qui se
passe sur le territoire
alors est ce que une entreprise si elle
a envie de conter et on va voir pourquoi
il aurait envie de compter ou une
collectivité territoriale et on pourrait
voir pourquoi elle aurait envie de
conter doivent compter exactement la
même chose si on se rappelle de la
physique
alors il est clair que le lieu
d'émission n'a strictement aucune
importance puisque vous mettez dans
l'atmosphère des gaz qui ont une
longévité de l'ordre du siècle on va
dire de la décennie au millénaire et
vous avez une durée de brassage intérêt
vis ferrique de votre atmosphère qui est
verte de l'année donc le lieu d'émission
de gaz à effet de serre n'a strictement
aucune espèce d'importance ou que ces
gaz / amy il engendre la même
modification climatique et à ce moment
vous pouvez avoir envie de mettre sur un
pied d'égalité les émissions qui se
passe ici et les émissions qui se passe
ailleurs
dès lors que toutes ces émissions qu'un
court à une même activité économique en
particulier une entreprise c'est un
acteur économique qui n'a jamais qui
n'est jamais autosuffisants
pour qu'une entreprise puisse vente de
lunettes elle a besoin de gens qui lui
vend de l'acier pour qu'elle est
dépendante de ses fournisseurs et elle a
besoin de gens qui voient pas bien parce
que il lui faut les clients donc une
entreprise d'une manière générale elle
est toujours dépendante d'autres acteurs
économiques et on peut éventuellement
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe chez elle
mais également à ce qui se passe en même
temps chez ses fournisseurs et chez ses
clients dans le but
avoir une vision globale de la chaîne
dans laquelle elle s'inscrit
et cette vision globale amène des
enseignements que n'a même pas une
vision purement territoriales donc
l'idée de la comptabilité carbone ou du
bilan carbone
ça dépend si vous prenez la méthode qui
est référencée sous un nom propre ou de
la méthode génériques
c'est très exactement celle là c'est que
comme dans une vraie comptabilité ou
vous avez des chiffres qui traduisent
des choses qui se passent ailleurs que
chez vous quand vous avez un compte de
charges dans la comptabilité d'une
entreprise ça traduit des choses qui se
sont passées ailleurs vous avez acheté
mais quelqu'un d'autre a dû produire et
bien exactement de la même manière dans
la comptabilité carbone
on va essayer de mettre en perspective
toutes les émissions dont une entreprise
dépend qu'elles se situent que les
émissions aient lieu chez elle donne par
exemple dans la chaudière d'un site de
production de verre ou bien ailleurs
dans un moteur de camion chez le
fournisseur chez les clients ou
n'importe où où les émissions une nuit
pour le compte d'un processus qui
profite à l'entreprise
alors quand je dis qui profite à
l'entreprise en fait je peux je peux
également dire dont l'entreprise dépend
dans son état actuel
donc l'idée centrale de la comptabilité
carbone ou du bilan carbone c'est que
vous ne regardez pas vous ne regardez le
critère qui vous permet de sélectionner
les émissions n'est pas un critère de
territorialité ça n'est pas un critère
de responsabilité la question n'est pas
de savoir si une entreprise est
responsable ou pas responsable de ce que
vous allez faire d'une voiture une fois
que vous l'avez acheté le maître mot et
celui de la dépendance
c'est à dire de quelle émission est ce
qu'une entreprise dépend pour être
capable d'avoir l'activité qu'elle a
aujourd'hui
et si je reprends l'exemple de la
voiture que j'aime prendre en filigrane
la question n'est pas de savoir si
renault est responsable ou pas
responsable de ce que vous allez faire
une fois que la voiture est vendue par
contre une chose est absolument certaine
c'est que si renault ne doit vendre que
des voitures dont on ne se sert pas
renault ne va pas être configuré
exactement comme renault est configuré
aujourd'hui donc l'idée centrale encore
une fois c'est on va mettre dans un même
paquet toutes les émissions dont dépend
une activité
économique alors quelques exemples et
bien si je fais le bilan carbone d'un
magasin je vais trouver là dedans
nécessairement les émissions des camions
ou des avions ou de l'électricité pour
faire avancer les trains qui ont été
nécessaires pour que les marchandises y
est jusque dans un magasin picard
magasin c'est un lieu d'échangés c'est
juste ça donc si je crée un lieu des
changes sans possibilité d' échanges
physiques c'est pas extrêmement pratique
de vendre donc vous allez trouver le
fret nord bilan carbone d'un magasin
si je suis maintenant à distributeur de
m va pour distribuer de l'eau potable
j'ai besoin d' usine pour la
comptabiliser j'ai besoin d'installer un
réseau qui permet d'acheminer l'eau
jusqu'à mes clients donc je vais trouver
assez logiquement dans le bilan carbone
de mon distributeur d'eau la fabrication
des tuyaux qui sont nécessaires pour que
l'eau puisse aller de mélusine jusqu'à
l'endroit où aller consommer si je
prends le bilan carbone la coiffeur et
bien vous allez trouver le chauffage du
magasin parce qu'un coiffeur qui n'est
pas chauffée l'hiver a généralement
assez peu de clients vous allez aussi
trouver les émissions de fabrication des
lacs ou bien les émissions de
déplacements des clients jusqu'au
magasin parce que si vous n'avez pas de
clients qui viennent dans le magasin
vous avez un chiffre d'affaires qui fait
grise mine
si vous êtes un constructeur d'immeubles
et bien vous allez trouver là aussi non
seulement les émissions de fabrication
de limon mais également les émissions de
fonctionnement de l'immeuble vendu 1
aujourd'hui les gens qui achètent un
bâtiment avec derrière la tête l'idée
que niveau chauffer ni vont avoir de
l'électricité niveau rentrer et sortir
ils ont utilisé les moyens de transport
pour s'en servir la clientèle pour ce
genre de choses aujourd'hui départ
extrêmement développée donc
objectivement si vous vendez un immeuble
vous avez besoin ensuite que cet
immeuble consomment de l'énergie peut
fonctionner tel que vous l'avez conçu
donc on va trouver ses émissions là dans
le bilan carbone d'un constructeurs
d'immeubles et enfin si vous êtes une
banque
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas avoir
d'activités financières
si vous n'avez pas aujourd'hui
d'ordinateurs donc on va assez
logiquement vous attribuer une petite
partie de l'électricité des centrales à
charbon qui auront permis
de faire les semi conducteurs qui auront
permis de faire les ordinateurs qui
permettront à la banque de faire du data
crushing donc vous allez trouver dans le
bilan carbone d'une banque
les émissions de fabrication de son
informatique et en fait si vous avez
jusqu'au bout de la logique vous devriez
aussi y trouver les émissions des
activités qui sont financés parce que
une banque si elle ne peut prêter
d'argent à personne
et bien elle a du mal aujourd'hui à
faire son métier c'est comme ça qu'elles
gagnent de l'argent
le maître mais encore une fois dans le
bilan carbone c'est celui de la
dépendance et vous pouvez appliquer
cette méthode a absolument n'importe
quelle activité économique ou para
économique on peut aussi faire le bilan
carbone de l'école des mines dans lequel
on va trouver des tas de choses diverses
et variées du restaurant un module
spécial pour les établissements
d'enseignement du bilan carbone qui a
été fait quand vos petits copains dicks
qui sera disponible à partir de
septembre vous pourrez constater que
même un endroit comme l'école des mines
n'échappe pas aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc l'idée encore une
fois c'est que on regarde non pas la
responsabilité mais là de tendance alors
si maintenant on regarde la manière de
compter les flux qui nous intéresse eh
bien on va se retrouver avec quelques
règles qui sont communes à tous les
inventaires d'émissions
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait une différence majeure entre bilan
carbone et les inventaires nationaux
dans le cadre de la convention climat
s'était excité à de territorialité par
contre il ya des critères qui sont
communs dans le critère qui sont communs
le premier d'entre eux c'est que on ne
compte que les gaz dont l'émission
modifie de manière douce cernable le
stock atmosphérique donc l'homme aimé
par exemple de la vapeur d'eau on aimait
de la vapeur d'eau quand on brûle des
hydrocarbures et de la vapeur d'eau dans
les hydrocarbures qui l hydrogène dans
les hydrocarbures
on aimait de la vapeur d'eau quand on
crée un barrage on aimait exactement on
supprime des flux ascendant de vapeur
d'eau en coupe une forêt il n'empêche
que ces modifications du cycle de l'eau
reste parfaitement marginale au regard
du cycle naturel de l'eau donc les
émissions humaines de vapeur d'eau ne
sont pas dans les inventaires
d'émissions pas plus que dans le bilan
carbone que dans les inventaires
nationaux parce que certes il
mission mais ça n'est pas ça n'a pas
d'effets discernable sur la quantité
totale de vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère
dont le premier élément qui la
gouvernent et la température moyenne de
l'air donc on va simplement prendre en
compte les gaz pour lequel on a un effet
discernable alors c'est typiquement le
cas du gaz carbonique
on a un effet discernable sur la
concentration atmosphérique donc sur le
forçage radiatif de ce gaz c'est le cas
du méthane
c'est le cas du protoxyde d'azoté c'est
le cas d'un certain nombre de lots
carbure mais par contre il n'ya pas la
vapeur d'eau dans la troposphère
il n'ya pas les émissions de co2
d'origine organique
puisque les émissions de co2 d'organes
d'origine organique dans la limite du
renouvellement de la biomasse
s'inscrivent dans le cycle naturel du
carbone donc ça on considère que ya pas
de perturbations a mené par l'homme dans
cette affaire et enfin une autre
restriction qu'on a aujourd'hui dans les
inventaires d'émissions c'est qu'on ne
tient pas cohérente du surplus de
concentration qui apparaît dans l'air
par suite d'une réaction chimique après
émissions de polluants primaires et ça
c'est typiquement le cas de l'eau du
rhône à l'ozone n'est pas unie sous
forme de zone sauf éventuellement par
les producteurs d'eau potable 24 de
l'oso nation de lomé sinon c'est pas il
s'arrache pas de cette manière
l'ozone harry dans l'atmosphère quand
vous avez est ni un cocktail de
polluants primaires
essentiellement ce qu'on appelle des
composés organiques volatils donc
typiquement du méthane ou de ou des
vapeurs d'essence des oxydes d'azoté et
vous touillez tout ça avec un peu de
lumière solaire et à ce moment vous avez
apparition de zone donc le zona paraître
n'est pas émis directement
il apparaît comme conséquence d'une
réaction chimique que vous avez dans
l'atmosphère et de ce fait comme vous ne
pouvez pas attribuer un lien de
responsabilité particulier à un acteur
particulier sur le supplément d'ozone
que vous avez fait naître dans
l'atmosphère ça n'est pas dans les
inventaires d'émissions
enfin la dernière chose qu'il faut
savoir c'est que l'unité de compte se
base en général
ce pardon se passe quand je lui étais
content du bilan carbone c'est comme
pour les inventaires d'émissions ce on
se base sur le prg à 100 en sachant
qu'il ya un long débat pour savoir si
c'est ce qui est approprié en ce qui
concerne le métal
pouvoir de réchauffement global ça
notamment s'était il me semble que ça
doit être non j'ai déjà dû prononcer ce
mot si maintenant on regarde on on va un
peu plus dans la technique
encore un peu plus dans la technique une
bonne partie des polluants pour une
bonne partie des polluants plus
exactement les émissions se mesure si
vous êtes dans l'industrie chimique les
émissions de protoxyde d'azoté dioxyde d
azote que vous avez en sortie d'une
cheminée vous les sortez pas d'un
chapeau
vous allez mettre des sondes vous allez
faire des mesures et vous allez
effectivement mesurer la quantité de ce
gaz qui quittent ou qui est émis dans
l'air dans le cadre du fonctionnement
d'autres usines
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
il n'y a pas ou il n'y a quasiment
jamais d'instrumentation spécifique pour
faire un bilan carbone
si l'un d'entre vous de sida les
prochaines de faire le bilan carbone de
l'école des mines
vous n'allez pas posé la moindre seconde
pour faire le bilan carbone de cette
institution
vous allez procéder d'une autre manière
tout simplement parce que c'est
physiquement impossible de venir tout
mesuré vous allez pas mettre une sombre
sortie de la chaudière etc
la manière dont vous allez faire c'est
que vous allez vous appuyer sur des
métrologies existantes c'est à dire des
choses qu'on peut déjà alors qu'est-ce
qu'on compte déjà ici mais par exemple
le nombre de gens qui viennent en
voiture le matin par exemple la quantité
de fioul que vous avez acheté pour
mettre dans la chaudière ou la quantité
de vapeur que vous avez acheté à la
compagnie parisienne de chauffage urbain
si ici on a un chauffage urbain etc etc
donc vous allez vous greffer sur des
métrologies existantes et vous à les
convertir les données d'activité où les
flux que vous avez récupéré de cette
manière en émissions qui sont donc des
émissions calculées avec quelque chose
qui s'appelle un facteur d'émission aura
facteurs d'émission c'est le résultat
d'un calcul qui vous permet de passer
d'un flux physiques
à d
mission qui que vous supposez avoir
vraiment pris place en l'occurrence ce
facteur d'émission lui il a souvent
nécessité ou une analyse de laboratoire
ou une instrumentation dans un cas
précis je vous donne un exemple tout
bête parce que ça c'est vraiment le truc
basique vous rentrez un litre d'essence
dans le moteur
eh bien il ya vraiment des motoristes
qui de manière très précise hongrie fier
que la totalité de l'essence était brûlé
et que la totalité du carbone qui
rentrait dans votre moteur ressortaient
bien à dépouiller m prêts sous forme de
co2 donc une fois on fait
l'instrumentation de manière très
précise et après est ce qu'on dit c'est
un litre d'essence rentrer dans un
moteur à combustion interne
ça fait tant de co2 et je n'ai plus
besoin de mesurer le co2 je le souhaite
quelquefois je sais ce que ça donne tout
ce que je vais mesurer sélénites
d'essence et là il se trouve que vous
avez une métrologie qui existent déjà
puisqu'il existe des pompes à essence
avec des conteurs dessus parce que ça
sert à les transactions commerciales
très souvent la métrologie sur laquelle
on va se baser
elle sert de grâce à une transaction
commerciale parce que c'est le cas de
figure typique dans lequel les gens font
un peu attention à ce qui leur arrive
un des cas de l'argent quelque part en
général on compte à peu près
correctement
donc le principe du facteur d'émission
c'est une instrumentation ou un calcul
dans un cas très particulier va dans un
cas à part donc on a regardé les choses
de près et ensuite vous à les appliquer
ou extrapoler ce que vous avez ou
calculée ou observer à des situations où
vous n'avez pas les moyens de refaire
les choses dans le détail alors le
facteur d'émission ça peut s'appliquer à
des tas de trucs je vous en donne est un
premier exemple
là c'est le facteur d'émission qui
correspond à la quantité de gaz à effet
de serre objectivement la quantité de
co2 nuit dans l'atmosphère
quand vous utilisez une tonne équivalent
pétrole d'une énergie fossile ou pas
possible alors pour les énergies
fossiles
il s'agit purement de l'énergie de
combustion donc ce que vous dit ce
graphique c'est que quand vous brûler
une tonne de gaz une tonne équivalent
pétrole par don de gaz eh bien ça vous
met de l'ordre de 650 kg équivalent
carbone de co2 dans l'atmosphère
etc etc et puis points de la ligne et ou
du coq de lignite
vous avez des émissions par unité
d'énergie qui sont beaucoup plus élevés
quand vous avez à la sacem
ça provient d'annalynne ce qui ont été
faites pour de vrai et quand vous êtes
dans une usine où vous ne faites pas ses
analyses mais où vous comptez les tonnes
de gaz à l'état d'équivalent pétrole de
gaz de pétrole ou de charbon qui rentre
et bien vous avez par contrecoup et qui
sont brûlés vous avez par contre coup
les émissions qui prennent place
derrière ça ce sont des analyses en
cyclo doni sa non c'est juste à
combustion ça c'est des analyses en
cycle de vie parce qu'il s'agit là pour
l'essentiel de sources d'énergie qui ne
conduisent pas à émettre en direct du
co2 dans l'atmosphère
comme je voulais expliquer lors des
séances précédentes
faire tomber de l'eau dans un garage ou
cassés des noyaux d'uranium en deux ou
faire tourner une éolienne en direct
satisfaction sauf qu'il a fallu
fabriquer les moyens de production il
faut le maintenir il faut et caetera et
ça par contre ça on fait un petit peu et
ça c'est typiquement le résultat d'un
calcul compliqué à pour pour produire ce
genre de résultat vous devez faire un
calcul qui est complexe
par exemple pour le nucléaire vous devez
tenir compte de l'activité minière amont
de la construction de la centrale
du fait que les salariés vont y venir du
fait même peut-être qu'on va les
chauffer du fait que l'on va devoir
traiter les déchets et c'est donc un
facteur d'émission
ça peut être très simples ou très
compliqué et mais au sein d'une même
catégorie
ça peut être très simples ou très
compliqué donc repris l'idée que c'est
toujours on part d'une situation dans
laquelle on a vraiment instrumenté et on
arrive derrière à quelque chose qu on
extrapole aux situations on ne peut pas
instrumenté autre exemple toujours
concernant l'énergie
ici vous avez les émissions de carbone
donc cédé kg équivalent carbone par
kilowattheure électrique produit
perdre un certain nombre de producteurs
européens
donc les producteurs d'électricité
européens utilisent chacun des centrales
à charbon des centrales à gaz des
centrales à fuel des barrages des
centrales nucléaires dans des
proportions variables et en fonction des
proportions de ses moyens de production
qui sont à leur disposition et bien le
contenu moyen du kilowattheure qui le
produisent contenu en carbone varie de
manière très significative
là vous n'avez que les émissions qui
sont liées aux combustibles donc là vous
avez des parts qui sont ou purement
nucléaire comme c'est le cas ici ou
purement des barrages comme c'est le cas
là bas vous allez aimer pour le
combustible et puis ailleurs ça varie en
fonction des moyens de production qui
sont utilisés
là c'est pareil vous voyez que c'est le
résultat laquelle qu'ils fassent ce truc
là est le résultat d'un calcul
le producteur d'électricité ils mesurent
pas le co2 en sortie de centrales ce qui
le mesure c'est la quantité de
combustible qui rentre voilà un autre
exemple de facteurs d'émission c'est la
quantité d'équivalent carbone qui peut
mettre dans l'atmosphère pour produire
une tonne de matériaux de base
donc je suis lafarge où je suis
holcim est bien ce quand j'ai fait une
tonne de ciment
j'ai mis dans l'atmosphère à peu près
200 kg équivalent carbone de co2 qui
provient du raid pour moitié de
l'énergie que j'ai utilisées et pour
moitié du fait que dans caco3 vous avez
co2 plus cae et donc quand vous faites
du clinquet roues de la chaux vive
à partir de calcaire et bien vous mettez
par molécule de carbonate de calcium
initial vous mettez une molécule de co2
dans l'atmosphère très difficile de
faire autrement quand vous produisez une
tonne de cuivre et bien vous rejeter
dans l'atmosphère en 800 kg équivalent
carbone de co2 là aussi c'est quelque
chose qui reflète l'activité minière qui
a pris place le raffinage du cuivre et
c'est donc encore une fois un facteur
d'émission même pour quelque chose qui
peut vous paraître simple comme comme
objet matériel
1 une tonne de faire une tonne de cuivre
une tonne de verre ça peut refléter des
processus assez complexe
voilà encore un exemple de facteurs
d'émission qui cette fois ci concerne
les transports
en ce qui concerne le voilà donc le ca
je vous l'avais déjà montré
je vais montrer quelque chose qui
ressemblait à ça là aussi ces facteurs
d'émission sont le résultat d'un calcul
qui en général prend en compte des
choses qui sont plus ou moins compliqué
en ce qui concerne le train là il s'agit
uniquement d'énergie de traction donc
point sncf et pour le royaume uni
et vous voyez apparaître ici par exemple
deux ou trois éléments qui vont
intervenir dans le calcul et qui vont
expliquer la grande différence entre les
deux c'est des émissions par
passager/kilomètre donc vous allez
commencer par faire les émissions d'un
train est ensuite vous les affecter au
nombre moyen de passagers qui transporte
donc vous voyez bien que ce genre de
calcul dépend de l'hypothèse que vous
allez faire sur le quai d'un lissage
donc dans un secteur des missions vous
pouvez avoir des hypothèses que vous
faites et qui sont légitimes et ou pas
selon l'utilisation que vous en faites
donc là vous voyez la différence entre
les 2 vient du taux de remplissage de la
manière de produire l'électricité en
france 90% en ordre de grandeur sans co2
en grande bretagne on est plutôt aux
alentours de 20 et le fait que ici vous
allez avoir plus de maîtrise au diesel
que la donc encore une fois cette notion
qui peut paraître là relativement simple
c'est à dire combien de gaz à effet de
serre sont émis pour que un passager
parcours 1 km en fait c'est le résultat
d'un calcul compliqué dans lequel vous
faites intervenir
le parc de production électrique le taux
de remplissage du train et le
pourcentage de motrice diesel dans
l'ensemble en ce qui concerne les avions
- vous avez également quelque chose qui
est très particulier qui concerne
uniquement ce mode de transport
les avions qui volent à ce qu'on a pas
qui volent à une altitude d'environ
10000 m vols entre les deux couches de
l'atmosphère qui s'appelle la
troposphère et la stratosphère la
troposphère et la couche la plus basse
de l'atmosphère celle qui touche le sol
celle dans laquelle nous vivons et elle
se termine à quelques kilomètres du sol
avec ce qu'on appelle une inversion de
température et le début de la
auxerre il se trouve que les avions
volent à la limite entre les deux aux
alentours de 10 km d'altitude les avions
utilise du kérosène et le kérosène d'un
hydrocarbure donc quand vous le brûler
vous allez faire du co2 et de la vapeur
d'eau une partie de cette vapeur de on
va se retrouver dans la stratosphère
et si la vapeur 2 ou qui est injecté
dans la troposphère c'est-à-dire là où
vous avez le cycle normal de l'eau est
une vapeur d'eau qui n'a pas d'incidence
sur les échanges d'énergie entre la
surface et là et l'espace ça n'est pas
parce qu'elle est recyclé trop vite ça
n'est pas vrai pour la vapeur 2 que vous
mettez dans la stratosphère qui va
distinctement modifier le forçage
radiatif de ce compartiment là ce n'est
pas dans les inventaires nationaux eux
par contre dans le bilan carbone en
tient compte et on tient compte
également du reste de la modification la
chimie de la haute atmosphère et vous
avez là aussi dans un facteur d'émission
qui peut paraître très simple en fait
des spéculations très compliqué qui ont
lieu sur la chimie de la haute
atmosphère et le devenir de la vapeur
d'eau atmosphérique que vous allez
retrouver incluse nador a séparé il n'y
a pas de métrologie à ce à quoi vous
faites voler un avion il ya eu des
mesures qui ont été faites par les
scientifiques dans un certain nombre de
cas de figure et vous avez extrapoler
ces mesures à ce qui se passe quand vous
faites voler n'importe quel avion voilà
un graphique que je vous avait déjà
montré qu'il a aussi concerne d'autres
facteurs d'émission qui sont les
facteurs d'édition liés à notre
alimentation
donc ces facteurs d'émission reflète la
quantité de gaz à effet de serre qui a
dû à trévise pour que l'on puisse in
fine et disposer d'un kilo de nourriture
en fonction du type de nourriture dont
il s'agit là c'est pareil
vous avez des calculs compliqués pour
arriver à ce genre de facteurs
d'émission parce que on ne va pas
instrumenté chaque vache avant qu'elle
parte à l'abattoir pour savoir
exactement combien de métal elle a émis
durant sa vie zablit donc vous vous avez
cela le temps vous avez vraiment pour de
vrai des agronomes de l'inra qui ont
dans certains cas de figure instrumenté
des lâches donc on leur a mis une espèce
de scapin
pour voir la quantité de méthane qui
exhalait et à partir de là eh bien vous
avez des valeurs que vous allez appliqué
à n'importe quel vaches
même quand vous la mettez pas dans un
scaphandre avant de la transformer en
vittek wiotte donc le facteur de
missions que vous avez ici ils sont
particulièrement compliqué d'abord parce
qu'il faut intervenir trop gaz alors que
la majeure partie des facteurs
d'émission vous allez trouver dans
l'industrie n'en font intervenir qu'un
pour trouver autre chose que du co2 dans
l'industrie à part quelques cas de
figure très particulier ça sera ça sent
pas le plus courant est par ailleurs ça
concerne des processus qui sont
extrêmement différents puisque ça peut
être de l'industrie ça peut être des
pratiques agricoles où ça peut être le
mécanisme elle est là la biologie de gaz
de l'animal que vous élevez donc un
facteur d'émission
ça n'est rien d'autre d'une certaine
manière qu'un bilan carbone que vous
avez déjà fait et que vous avez ramené à
une unité de production
finalement c'est ça un facteur
d'émission
si je vous dis que le bilan carbone est
basé sur des facteurs d'émission et si
je vous dis que les émissions c'est
toujours le produit données d'activité
flou un facteur d'émission
je vous ai dit que le bilan carbone
était une méthode linéaire
le bilan carbone est nécessairement une
méthode linéaire à partir du moment où
vous avez émission eyal données
d'activité froid facteurs d'émission on
peut du reste se poser la question de
savoir si c'est la bonne manière de
comptes eux puisqu'on a essentiellement
à faire avec le changement climatique un
processus non linéaire mais enfin en
attendant c'est comme ça qu'on compte
pour le moment faute de mieux
ce qui veut dire que le principe général
du bilan carbone sera toujours être le
même
vous allez pour un certain nombre de
postes
par exemple ici il s'agit des voyages en
avion en pleurs courrier et
place regardez quelle est la donnée
d'activité que vous pouvez récupérer là
ici en l'occurrence il s'agit de
kilomètres parcourus par les salariés
d'une entreprise dans l'année or je
prends une entreprise ces salariés ont
acheté 194 milles kilomètres de voyage
en avion court courrier dans l'année
j'applique est ce là un facteur
d'émission qui est donc le résultat
parce que évidemment encore une fois je
vais pas les mettre une sonde à la
sortie des réacteurs des avions qui ont
été pris par ces gens là donc j'applique
un facteur d'émission qui est le
résultat d'un calcul et j'obtiens en
sortie les émissions que je considère
avoir pris place en contrepartie de ce
que j'ai vraiment mesuré c'est à dire
des kilomètres en avion donc c'est ça le
principe encore une fois général de la
comptabilité carbone c'est que vous vous
appuyez sur des facteurs d'émission
c'est un système de prix d'une certaine
manière
quand vous achetez des tonnes de blé bah
en fait c'est temps la tonne soit le
nombre de tonnes que vous achetez c'est
exactement pareil sauf que ici au lieu
d'avoir un prix monétaire on commence
par un prix en émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est c'est quelque chose avec
lequel vous pouvez absolument tout
compté puisque vous avez vu que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il y
en avait dans absolument tous puisque
dans absolument tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui vous avez un moment ou un
autre de l'énergie fossile qui est
rentré en ligne de compte donc des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
en avez dans absolument
donc on peut se servir de ça comme unité
de compte c'est légitime alors une fois
qu'on a compté les flux individuel on va
chercher à les agrégés par grands postes
c'est qu'en général comme ça qu'on
fonctionne dans la majeure partie des
organisations vous avez des gens qui
sont en charge de quelque chose
donc vous allez chercher à donner à ces
gens là
une indication qui les concernent eux de
manière importante et qui est qui
concerne moins les autres
dans le cadre de la répartition du
travail avec un premier poste
d'agrégation concerne à toutes les
sources qui sont fixes et qui ont lieu
sur site
imaginons par exemple que vous soyez
chez un verrier bas vous allez trouver
les la rue là vous allez trouver le fond
en verre et en bas vous allez
éventuellement trouver les engins qui
sont sur place je pas des pelleteuses
des camions d'élections les navettes etc
qui vont servir à du transport sans
quitter le site
un deuxième poste d'agrégation concerne
les déplacements des personnes qui
travaillent ou des personnes qui
viennent sur site
qu'il s'agisse de clients qu'il s'agisse
de fournisseurs qu'ils s'agit de
journalistes qu'il s'agisse de ce que
vous voulez de candidats à l'embauché
en bref vous allez trouver des
déplacements de personnes quelles qu'en
soient les raisons et qui sont liées à
l'activité dans un autre post encore
vous allez trouver la fabrication des
intrants donc comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure une entreprise une activité
productive ça s'inscrit dans une chaîne
ça ne fonctionne jamais tout seul donc
vous allez trouver dans un post séparer
les émissions qui ont eu lieu en amont
pour pouvoir permettre à l'entreprise où
l activité d'exercer sa de pouvoir
auquel vous allez trouver un segment de
fret qui est le déplacement de ce qui a
été produit ailleurs jusqu'à l'endroit
où l'entreprise on fera quelque chose
vous allez trouver le pendant qu'ils
aient la livraison aux clients
vous allez trouver les émissions de fin
de vie des déchets qui sont jetés les
déchets qui sont jetés peuvent engendrer
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans deux cas de figure
la méthanisation dessus et organique si
sa part en décharge ou la combustion du
carbone fossile si sa part en
incinérateur
vous allez trouver une utilisation
car il est bien évident qu'il n'y a pas
de produits vendus s'ils ne peuvent pas
utiliser ou de services vendus s'ils ne
peuvent pas utiliser et simple est de
très loin le prg est dominant par
exemple si vous faites le bilan carbone
d'une agence de voyages l' agence de
voyages
sa source fixe c'est le but chaudière de
l'immeuble dans lequel elle se trouvait
s'est totalement négligeable face aux
émissions d'utilisation de ce qu'elles
vont c'est à dire de billets d'avion et
les billets de train donc les émissions
d'utilisation ça peut être dominant dans
le bilan carbone d'une entreprise ou
d'une activité
si on considère que l'école des mines
forme des gens pour construire des hauts
fourneaux et des avions et à ce moment
c'est les émissions d'utilisation des
ingénieurs de l'école des mines qui vont
être dominante dans le bilan carbone de
l'école des mines et enfin vous avez la
fin de vie des produits ou services
vendus donc par exemple votre
incinération dans très longtemps et la
méthanisation pour vous allez être
l'objet donc vous allez trouver ici la
fin de vie alors dd dans des exemples d
exemple un peu moins exotique par
exemple vous convier des magazines
l'essentiel des gens après les avoir lus
les jette
sauf celui dans lequel il ya eu le
placement d'entrée que vous conservez
religieusement mais tous les autres
voulait jeter et à ce moment ça va vous
faire des émissions de fin de vie pour
la partie du papier que vous jetez qui
finit en mai qui finit en décharge et
qui engendre de la méthanisation
le périmètre exact les frontières du
système sont en fait des frontières qui
sont définis en fonction du cas de
figure à partir du moment où vous
décidez que le maître mot et celui de la
dépendance
c'est à l'utilisateur qu'il appartient
de définir correctement les frontières
de son système et les frontières du
système normalement elles sont définies
de telle sorte que à l'extérieur de ses
frontières
ce qu'il vous arrive à vous la plus d'
influence dans banon c'est comme ça que
vous devez correctement les définir il
est bien évident que dans la majeure
partie des méthodes pas de 2,2 des
inventaires qui sont effectués il ya une
tentation qui sait du lampadaire et que
vous connaissez bien qui consiste à
chercher là où il ya de la lumière donc
connaissez cette blague qui a perdu ses
clefs et bien là c'est exactement pareil
il ya la même tentation qui arrive de
temps en temps qui consiste à dire je ne
démesurée
que là où j'ai de la visibilité et je ne
m'intéresse pas à ce qui est un peu trop
exotiques
alors que éventuellement le lien de
dépendance peut être absolument majeur
je vais vous donner un autre exemple
vous êtes une boutique qui vend des
cocottes en papier dans un aérogare ou
dans une aérogare s'était baptisé
masculin féminin
il est évident que vos émissions
directes et directement induite sont
totalement négligeable d'être dans un
petit local mal chauffés fabriquer les
cocottes en papier ça ça qui aimait
beaucoup etc
il n'empêche que vous êtes tributaire
d'un flux clientèle qui lui a besoin
d'une énergie fossile abondante et à bas
prix pour exister donc pas si vous
faisiez de bilan carbone de cette
activité par exemple se posait la
question de savoir où vous devez mettre
les frontières du système que vous
étudiez pour avoir une bonne idée des
liens de dépendance
c'est pas toujours trivial pas toujours
très bien cette méthode vous pouvez
aussi l'appliquer à une collectivité est
une collectivité territoriale
je vais prendre par exemple une mairie
souvent une commune ou une ville c'est
que l'on peut comprendre le terme
collectivités territoriales de deux
manières d'abord on peut comprendre ce
terme comme l'ensemble des gens qui
fournissent des services à une
collectivité données si vous allez dans
une ville par exemple la ville a la
charge d'administrer la voirie
d'entretenir les routes
elle a la charge de gérer les écoles
primaires elle a la charge d'entretenir
les espaces verts etc ok un certain
nombre de prestataires de services d'un
genre particulier
et alors à ce moment l'adaptation du
bilan carbone qui a été fait a été de
dire que pour chacun de services fournis
par la collectivité
on va faire un bilan carbone simplifiée
parce qu'un certain nombre de postes
qu'on n'est pas pour un prestataire de
cette nature par exemple on considère
qu'il n'ya pas d'utilisation des
produits vendus 1
dans les services rendus par une
collectivité voilà donc vous faites ça
pour l'administration l'enseignement le
faire de logements gérés et caetera et à
ce moment vous avez la possibilité de
raisonner soit en regardant ce que ça
donne service par service soit en
regardant ce que ça donne celui par flux
par exemple vous pouvez regarder la
totalité des chaudières qui sont
utilisés pour la totalité de ses
activités et regardez ce que ça vaut
dans le total donc vous pouvez adapter
la comptabilité carbone à autre chose
qu'une entreprise donc là c'est un
premier exemple concernant une
collectivité territoriale
un deuxième exemple concernant une
collectivité territoriale ccit vous
considérez votre collectivité comme
étant un bout de territoire
1le quand je parle de la ville de paris
je peux parler des services de la ville
de paris où je peux parler du territoire
ville de paris sur lequel habite 2
millions de personnes avec les activités
économiques qui sont les siennes et c
est à ce moment la manière dont je vais
compter va commencer à ressembler à cela
manière donc encore dans le cadre des
inventaires d'émissions dans le cadre de
la convention climat mais pas tout à
fait parce que je vais quand même
rajouter un certain nombre de choses qui
n'y sont pas allés dans les choses qui
ressemblent à ce que je veux trouver
dans la dans les inventaires petit
convention climat je vais avoir ce qui
est ce qu'on appelle la production
d'énergie qui n'est en fait pas de la
production comme vous l'avait expliqué
il ya quelques cours mais plutôt de la
transformation donc si vous avez ici une
centrale à facile d'aller sur votre
territoire une centrale à charbon à un
autre chaleur etc
vous allez en tenir compte ça c'est
aussi dans l'inventaire de type le fccc
après vous avez mais sur se fixent des
industriels donc vous avez quelqu'un qui
fait de l'acier quelqu'un qui fait du
beurre quelqu'un qui fait du ciment et
cetera
vous allez également trouvé ça après
vous avez les émissions liées aux
procédés agricoles qui prennent place
sur votre territoire donc là c'est
pareil vous avez des vaches vous avez
des canards
des cochons etc tout ça ça y est vous
avez des chances sur lesquels on répand
des engrais ça ça et mais ça c'est
également c'est sûr selon elles sont
également dans l'inventaire national
c'est à dire que si je fais le bilan
carbone de la france je prends
l'ensemble de la france je vais
également
je trouve ça exactement comme dans
l'inventaire national commission on va
trouver les émissions qui ont lieu dans
les sites dits percière alors que ces
quatre sites tertiaires pas typiquement
là où nous sommes un établissement
d'enseignement intensif tertiaire à 9
degrés est un site tertiaire un hôpital
est un site tertiaire une crèche est un
site percière etc
c'est toutes les activités marchandes ou
non marchandes qui ne sont pas des
activités industrielles
on va trouver l'endroit où les gens
habitent là aussi tout cela on reste
dans les sources qui sont exactement
celles qui sont prises en compte dans le
cadre des inventaires nationaux
là on va commencer à sortir des règles
de l'inventaire national
quand on regarde le fret parce que on ne
va plus regarder ce qui circule sur le
territoire oui ou plus exactement pas
seulement ce qui circule sur le
territoire on va regarder les flux de
transport dont le territoire dépend pour
assurer son activité actuelle donc
anglais on va s'intéresser à tous les
camions viennent livrer quelque chose
sur le territoire et qui sont
nécessaires pour que le territoire
puissent vivre comme il vit aujourd'hui
on va trouver tous les camions et les
trains et les avions qui prennent des
marchandises sur le territoire qu'ils
exportent en dehors du territoire parce
que ça aussi c'est nécessaire à la vie
économique du territoire tel cas se
présente aujourd'hui et ces flux là et
eux ils ne sont pas dans les inventaires
nationaux c'est à dire que si vous
faites le bilan carbone de la france
vous allez trouver les transports qui
nous servent commerce extérieur alors
que vous ne les trouvez pas dans
l'inventaire dans le cadre de la
convention climat
même motif même punition on va résonner
exactement de la même manière pour les
transports de personnes
donc si je fais l'inventeur des missions
de la côte d'azur au sens 'reporting'
dans le cadre de la convention climat et
là je vais trouver
déplacement des résidents qui vont
jamais être méchant de la maison de
retraite de la côte d'azur jusqu'à la
place si je fais l'inventeur des
missions de la côte d'azur au sens du
bilan carbone
eh bien je les trouvais les voitures des
parisiens qui viennent passer leurs
vacances plus les voitures des allemands
qui viennent passer leurs vacances plus
les avions de l'andelle des danois qui
viennent passer leurs vacances plus les
avions des russes qui viennent passer
leurs vacances etc
et ça fait une grosse différence ça fait
une grosse différence donc je vais
trouver les flux de transport de
personnes dont la vie économique de la
côte d'azur dépend aujourd'hui je vais
trouver là quelque chose qui est
également étrange et à la convention
climat pour une large part c'est à dire
que je vais trouver les émissions de
construction des bâtiments qui prennent
place à qui son qui sont des bâtiments
et d'infrastructures qui prennent place
dans le territoire que je suis en train
de regarder et ses émissions bien
évidemment elle vapeur partie
correspondre aux industriels qui sont
sur mon territoire si j'ai une
cimenterie sur le territoire on suggère
la syrie sur territoire
mais si je le dis en carbone de la ville
de paris par exemple où il y a sauf
erreur de ma part ni cimenterie ni à
syrie je vais trouver dans ce poste-là
essentiellement les émissions qui auront
lieu dans les hauts fourneaux et chez
les cimentiers ailleurs que sur la ville
mais qui sont quand même nécessaire pour
que l'on puisse construire des immeubles
dans la ville et enfin je vais trouver
le traitement des déchets qui sont émis
sur le territoire et je vais également
trouvé la fabrication de skis se
rajouter derrière j'en profite pour
faire une petite incidente
quand vous jetez à kg de plastique ou un
kg de métal l'essentiel de la pollution
climatique lié à ce geste n'est pas
propre à ce qui se passe après que vous
ayez jeter elle a déjà pris place avant
que vous ne l'étiez en d'autres termes
quand vous jetez acquis le plastique
dans une poubelle
l'essentiel des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre a lieu au moment où ce
plastique a été produit et non pas le
moment
ce plastique sera gérée derrière par le
système de traitement des déchets ce qui
veut dire que le fait de remplir sa
poubelle engendre une pollution
climatique entre guillemets qui est
essentiellement liée au fait d'avoir
fabriqué que derrière on gère comme ceci
ou on gère comme cela n'a plus qu'une
influence marginale sur les émissions
globales liées au fait de jeter quelque
chose
donc c'est pas il faut pas se tromper de
problème la solution au problème des
déchets n'est pas de bien les gérer une
fois qu'on les htc essentiellement donne
pas les avoir achetés jeu donc je je je
reviens brièvement là dessus les
émissions que vous trouvez là sont les
éditions qui correspond de traitement de
ce qui est émis par le territoire c'est
pas les décharges qui prennent place
mais incinérateurs qui prennent place
sur le territoire c'est les déchets qui
sont émis par le territoire alors vous
verrez enfin vous voyez que par rapport
un bilan carbone d'entreprise ya des
trous il ya une partie de ce qui est
nécessaire à l'activité du territoire
qui n'est pas par exemple les gens
généralement m 3 par jour dans la
nouvelle se fasse que ce qu'ils mangent
soit déjà pris en compte la vous n'allez
pas trouver les émissions de production
des aliments du territoire dans cette
comptabilité particulière pour le moment
ça pourrait être ajoutée derrière mais
probablement sagnier pas vous acheter
une paire de lunettes se fasse que les
émissions correspondantes soient déjà
pris en compte parce que le producteur
de lunettes est situé chez vous eh bien
vous n'allez pas trouvé non plus les
émissions de production en question donc
dans la proche territoire la différence
par rapport aux inventaires type le fccc
il y en a deux la première c'est que il
ya des flux qui vont chercher à
l'extérieur du territoire et la deuxième
c'est que maman c'est une approche un
trou dans le bilan carbone
essentiellement parce que d'abord de la
visibilité parce que la métrologie
pour en revenir à ce que j'ai tout à
l'heure la métrologie qui permet
d'approcher ces flux
de manière à peu près 100 c'est pour le
moment elle n'est pas encore un point
une des questions qui se posent quand
vous faites ce genre d' analyse est de
savoir qu'est ce que vous devez garder
pour vous exactement quels sont les
secrets de fabrique qu'il faut pas
divulgué et quelles sont les choses qui
leur est sur la table en ce qui concerne
le bilan carbone et ça c'est applicable
à une large partie des méthodes qui sont
mises en oeuvre par des prestataires de
services
vous avez une partie qui est tout à fait
unique qui concerne la manière de conter
et les facteurs d'émission avec lesquels
vous pouvez en pratique
comptez donc si je prends l'exemple du
bilan carbone
l'ademe qui est donc l' agence
gouvernementale qui est chargé de
promouvoir les économies d'énergie
2 tout à fait gratuitement à la fois ce
qu'on appelle un guide méthodologique
c'est à dire les règles qui doivent être
suivis pour conter et les facteurs
d'émission qui permet de commencer la
comptabilité sachant qu'en général on en
rajoute toujours dans un bilan carbone
donner parce qu'il y en a jamais assez
ça c'est le côté ouvert est réfutable de
de ce genre de méthode qui à mon avis il
est absolument indispensable parce que
si vous expliquez pas comment vous
comptez vous tombez dans la boîte noire
et quand vous tombez dans la boîte noire
c'est très difficile de se servir des
chiffres que vous produisez dans un des
vendanges d'un débat public
et puis vous avez quand même une partie
qui est privé entre guillemets c'est à
dire les logiciels ou les tableurs qui
permettent effectivement de faire la
comptabilité avec cette ligne
elle peut se séparer plus ou moins elle
peut se déplacer plus ou moins en
fonction de la méthode
de confins de la manière où le ou la
belle on va dire de la méthode que vous
êtes en train de regarder
vous avez des méthodes dans lesquelles
les logiciels sont en libre accès il ya
des bouts de tableur qui circulent
gratuitement 20 typiquement le bilan
carbone campus qui sera proposé à partir
de septembre pour faire le bilan carbone
des établissements d'enseignement et
donc les gens comme vous fasse un peu la
main et bien la ligne
elles se déplacent jusque là pas
totalité sera disponible en libre accès
vous avez des méthodes propriétaires
donc des sociétés qui ont développé leur
propre base de données avec lesquels
elle travaille ou par contre la ligne
elle va jusque là c'est à dire
absolument rien n'est public souhaite
éventuellement les règles avec
lesquelles on compte 1 le fait qu' on a
un poste pour tenir compte des sources
fixes et un poste pour tenir compte des
déplacements en voiture voilà à part ce
genre de choses rien les publics et en
particulier pas ça donc le principe
général là je voulais des gens de vie en
carbone le principe général dans ce
genre de méthode c'est que vous pouvez
aller de tout public à tout prix mais
avec une frontière entre les deux qui
peut se déplacer en fonction de la
méthode que vous êtes en train de
regarder tout ça c'est la manière de
conter et bien évidemment ce qui
deviendra en sait quand on commence à
regarder ce qu'on a vraiment trouvé
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
parce que c'est ces exemples finalement
qui vont vous permettre de comprendre ce
que signifie de se confronter à la
contrainte à la contrainte carbone et
donc à la question à la fois des
ressources et des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ici je prends un
distributeur d'eau alors un distributeur
d'eau c'est quoi c'est une entreprise
industrielle dont l'activité consiste à
construire des stations pour produire de
l'eau potable
cette eau potable elle peut soit la
puiser dans une nappe s'étend pas
potable ou potable cela dépend des cas
de figure elle peut la puiser dans une
nappe s'ils allaient pas potable la
rampe potable elle peut la puiser dans
une rizière
c'est également une source
d'approvisionnement très importante
par exemple pour la banlieue de paris
une partie de l'eau est puisée dans des
guerres elle est ce qu'on appelle
potabilisée de potabiliser ça veut dire
qu'on va naître des réactifs divers
dedans pour enlever les cochonneries qui
s'y trouvaient va on va là décanter on
va etc
puis elle est envoyée dans les tuyaux
qu'il a donc fallu poser sous pression
jusqu'au moment enfin jusqu'à l'endroit
où vous pouvez ouvrir le robinet une
telle entreprise a donc besoin d'énergie
pour fonctionner à double titre d'abord
elle en a besoin sous forme électrique
pour faire fonctionner les pompes qui
vont permettre de mettre louhans
pression c'est essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle des pompes de relèvement donc
c'est des trucs qui luttent contre la
gravité et qui vont permettre de mettre
l'eau sous pression parce que si vous
n'avez pas d'eau sous pression ils vous
ouvrez le robinet mais se passe rien et
vous voyez que ici c'est un des postes
importants dans le bilan carbone de
d'une activité de cette nature ça a été
fait ce bilan carbone en france donc si
je l'avais fait en allemagne en italie
en grande bretagne aux états unis et
c'est la barre électricité serait
n'importe quoi entre le 3 et 6 fois plus
haute
bien évidemment ensuite vous avez une
deuxième grande barre qui concerne toute
la maintenance du réseau
ça c'est quoi ces les émissions qui sont
nécessaires pour fabriquer les tuyaux en
fonte ou en pvc que vous allez devoir
vous poser parce qu'il ya des endroits
qui s'urbanise donc il faut le ramener
l'eau potable ou bien pour remplacer les
tuyaux qui sont rongés par la rouille ou
bien qu'ils ont cassé ou bien qui ont
explosé etc
c'est les nouveaux compteurs qu'on va
mettre chez les abonnés quand on décide
de passer d'un claude compteur de telles
catégories à des compteurs de paie
l'autre catégorie par exemple si on vous
met les compteurs électroniques
c'est le service qui sont achetés par
cette entreprise parce qu'il faut gérer
des dizaines de milliers
ou de centaines de milliers de factures
donc il faut acheter des informaticiens
des services informatiques etc
donc vous avez là dedans tous les
fournisseurs au sens large que ce soit
des fournisseurs de matériel ou des
fournisseurs de prestations de services
qui va permettre à ces gens là de faire
leur métier
vous allez trouver ici une autre barre
pas complètement ridicule qui concerne
du gasoil d'engins de chantier car poser
un tuyau c'est essentiellement maître du
gasoil dans un tractopelle ouvrir une
tranchée poser de tuyaux toujours maître
du gasoil dans le tractopelle refermer
la tranchée avant ça se faisait que des
pelles et des pioches c'était un peu
plus on est un peu plus cher maintenant
on fait ça avec des engins de chantier
et ça représente quelque chose qui n'est
pas complètement ridicule dans la
manière de faveur dans le total des
émissions de 7 cette entreprise a la
gouaille et sur l'exemple que je vous
laisse imaginer le que vous arriviez
chez eux avec le discours ambiant sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
les transports 1,8
avant de regarder chez vous je sais ce
que je vais faire je vais mettre en
place un plan de déplacement pour qu'il
y ait du covoiturage du etc
alors on peut toujours faire mais vous
voyez qu'en fait ça concernerait des
postes qui ne sont pas dominant dans
l'inventaire de cette société
particulière et là il manque une barre
extrêmement importante dans ce guide en
carbone est ce que vous savez laquelle
il ya une barre absolument majeur qui
manque dans ce bilan carbone pardon non
personne ne voit l'eau en général vous
l'utilisez à quelle température toujours
froide toujours à part ceux qui prennent
pas de douche souvent non bon une bonne
partie de l'oeil vous allez utiliser
should qu'il s'agisse de prendre une
douche de faire fonctionner à la devez
celle de faire fonctionner à la linge
etc
une fraction très importante de l'eau
consommée chaussures et quand elle est
acheminée par un distributeur d'eau
potable et ça c'est une barre qui n'a
passé quelque chose qui n'a pas été
évalué dans le cadre de ce bilan carbone
n'a mais vous verrez qu'il ya à
l'évidence un lien de dépendance sur ce
poste là puisque si vous contraignez
l'utilisation de l'énergie en général et
de l'énergie fossile en particulier ça
coûtera plus cher de faire chauffer de
l'eau donc il ya une partie des familles
où on finira par trouver un excellente
arts vivants pour que les gens arrêtent
de rester des heures sous la douche
ok on fasse tourner le lave vaisselle
quand il est vraiment bien plein et une
fois que ce genre de processus se met en
oeuvre et bien allez volume de vendus
par mon activité de distribution 2
baisse donc envoyé un exemple typique où
le fait d'avoir élargi le champ de
vision vous donne une indication sur
quelque chose qui pourrait se passer et
qui traduit clairement un lien de
dépendance
un autre exemple un opérateur de
téléphone
vous allez le dire le téléphone c'est
percière donc ça débutera de gaz à effet
serre et d'une manière générale c'est
bien connu que les gens dans un bureau
où ça n'aimaient pas de gaz à effet de
serre vous verrez après que c'est une
conclusion qu'on peut dans seront
discutées mais ses bras donc on en est
là et on regarde un opérateur de
téléphone alors un opérateur de
téléphone la première chose dont il a
besoin pour pouvoir vous permettre de
téléphoner c'est essentiellement d'avoir
un réseau parce que
avoir une activité ou qui consiste à
vendre des communications téléphoniques
qui n'avait pas de réseau sur lesquels
les faire passer c'est un peu difficile
donc la première chose dont vous avez
besoin c'est de construire un réseau
dans les commissions de construction de
votre réseau et bien vous allez
retrouver les émissions des gens qui ont
fabriqué les composants du réseau donc
l'épisode en acier l'électronique qui
vend en pied de l'antenne etc
les tranchées qu'on a dû ouvrir et les
câbles qu'on a dû poser quand il s'agit
de réseaux filaires bon bref vous avez
des émissions qui sont liées à la
construction du réseau
ensuite vous téléphonez difficilement si
vous n'avez pas un téléphone chez vous
ou si vous n'avez pas acheté un
téléphone portable
donc vous allez trouver là aussi des
émissions parce que il a fallu fabriquer
des téléphones en général ensuite
l'opérateur de téléphonie vous aura des
factures parce que c'est rare qu'ils
fassent ça une fois vos beaux yeux
donc il faut fabriquer le papier pour
les factures il faut les imprimés il
faut les envoyer
enfin un poste qui est parfaitement
secondaire dans cette affaire qu'il a
pour le coup a été pris en compte
c'est l'électricité de fonctionnement
des téléphones eux-mêmes
1 donc vous voyez bien que dans les
émissions globales liées au fait d'avoir
un réseau de télécoms la consommation
des équipements terminaux n'est pas
nécessairement le sujet premier donc on
peut faire de gros efforts que les
téléphones consoles un peu moins c'est
alain que le principal point de
vulnérabilité d'une activité comme celle
ci même la consommation du réseau n'est
pas quelque chose qui est le point
dominant dans une activité de cette
nature vous pouvez y est un autre
exemple
alors évidemment la question que vous
pouvez vous poser ses admettons que le
prix de l'énergie fossile moite
ce qui veut dire
d'une certaine manière que de construire
le réseau et me coûte de plus en plus
cher comment c'est quoi le service que
je vends dans un contexte dans lequel la
course au gigabit n'est plus possible
les shebab
alors les barrières dans le temps là en
l'occurrence elles ont été placées de
manière très simple puisqu'il s'agissait
du flux annuel d'accroissement et
maintenance du réseau
parce que même une fois que le réseau
est construit il faut continuer à
maintenir les équipements ont une
certaine obsolescence est par ailleurs
quand vous avez quand vous avez des
équipements qui nécessitent de plus en
plus de bande passante et bien vous avez
besoin périodiquement de rajouter
électronique qui permet de faire ce
genre de chose quand vous avez donc
c'est ça c'est vrai à la fois pour les
réseaux filaires et pour les réseaux
sans fil l'adsl aujourd'hui nécessite
des équipements dans l'est dans l'espoir
appelait autrefois les centraux
téléphoniques supplémentaires
bien que le réseau filaire lui il a été
posé dans un certain nombre d'endroits
il ya des dizaines d'années d'accord
donc en fait vous avez ce genre de
choses même si le réseau existe et en
faites ce que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure sur mon opérateur de c'était
exactement pareil c'est à dire que votre
réseau de distribution il existe ce que
la population augmente un peu sauf qu'il
ya des zones qui se mettent à
s'urbaniser sûr qu'un tuyau saviez sa
vie 50 ou 80 ans et pas cinq ans à paris
par cinq siècles
donc il faut même si on a raison
installé périodiquement remplacer rénové
et c'est cette même réflexion s'applique
aussi à des routes par exemple une fois
que la route a déconstruit tu m'as
périodiquement faudra placer la chaussée
donc c'est c'est clair que ce genre de
discussion a toujours lieu quand vous
avez affaire à quelque chose qui existe
déjà de savoir comment vous devez le
prendre en compte
alors la seule chose qui est certaine
c'est que si vous détruisez le réseau
déjà installés c'est pas ça qui fera que
le carbone ne repartira sous terre voilà
ça c'est absolument certain
un autre exemple ici vous avez une
société de bâtiment et travaux publics
alors une société de bâtiment et travaux
publics
elle fait essentiellement une chose
c'est que elle prend de l'acier et du
béton et elle en fait des logements des
immeubles divers des hôpitaux des
stations d'épuration des ponts des
viaducs des tunnels revoilà celle à
l'utilisation absolument magique d'une
certaine manière d'un matériau de
construction qui s'appelle le béton
j'ai mis en utilisation parce que la
quasi totalité des objets qui sont
vendus par ce genre de société nécessite
de l'énergie derrière pour être utilisés
si vous construisez un peu routier c'est
assez rare que l'on construise un pont
routier pour qu'il y ait zéro voitures
qui passent dessus donc en général une
infrastructure de transport
elle va être fait pour être utilisé et
dont vous allez avoir des émissions
d'utilisation
ça reste vrai si vous construisez une
voie de chemin de fer ça reste vrai si
vous construisez un canal ça reste vrai
si vous construire un port et ça reste
vrai aussi si vous construisez une
station d'épuration ça reste vrai si
vous construisez un immeuble etc
donc il ya des émissions d'utilisation
qui ne sont pas dans cet ensemble dans
la société de bâtiment et travaux
publics
je vais trouver un premier poste très
important qui sont qui représente la
contrepartie des matériaux de
construction qui ont été fabriqués
produit pour le compte de mon activité
donc je vais retrouver en fait ici des
émissions qui ont vraiment eu lieu dans
un four ne dans la fin de cimentiers et
qui sont la contrepartie de l'acier du
ciment que j'utilise après je vais avoir
un deuxième poste important qu'ils aient
les engins de chantier et puis les
usines que j'ai en propre parce que la
quasi totalité des sociétés de btp
elles ont des usines en propre pour
fabriquer ce qu'on appelle les enrobés
s'il vous plaît je vous libère dans
trois minutes mais pour fabriquer ce
qu'on appelle les enrobés et les arts au
bc des gravillons enrobé leurs noms
l'indiquent d'un peu de bitume et pour
faire ce genre de choses il faut
chauffer et ça ça nécessite de consommer
de l'énergie
là c'est pareil vous voyez on peut
commencer à se poser la question qui est
si ce genre de choses commencent à
coûter de plus en plus cher parce que
l'énergie qui permet leur fabrication
coûte de plus en plus cher si ce genre
de choses commencent à coûter de plus en
plus cher c'est quoi la bonne manière de
continuer à avoir des clients et à la
vente des choses si je veux faire
baisser utilement les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre comment est ce que je me
prends est ce que par exemple à une
partie des trucs que je peux construire
en bois est ce que je peux
utiliser plus de soucis et moins de ceux
là est ce que je peux avoir des
ingénieurs structures qui sont bien
meilleurs et qu'ils vont m'économiser de
la matière pour avoir des mêmes
propriétés mécaniques etc
donc ça faisait deux questions de cette
nature et puis la sarre en pause
d'autres qui concerne l'efficacité des
processus les quantités de matériaux mis
en oeuvre la température à laquelle vous
devez porter ce que vous fabriquez pour
avoir un résultat intéressant etc etc
un dernier exemple avant de passer à
pardon à la suite si une banque alors
une banque c'est des gens dans un bureau
des gens dans un bureau c'est mais pas
de gaz à effet de serre c'est bien connu
du reste vous allez ressortir de cette
salle de cours aussi propre ou sale pour
ceux qui en parlent aux chaudes que vous
êtes entré d'une manière générale dans
un bureau on considère qu'il se passe
rien ou pas grand chose qui ne mettent
en jeu d'énergie
c'est faux et c'est parfaitement faux un
premier poste par lequel afin qu'il va
concerner ma banque
c'est que en général aujourd'hui si vous
ne chauffez pas les bureaux de vos
salariés l'hiver voir si vous les
climatiser pas l'été les salariés
rouspète sont moins productifs
éventuellement démissionne donc vous
avez un premier poste qui est important
qui va être le chauffage et puis vous
allez avoir un deuxième poste important
qui va être l'électricité en france vous
avez à peu près la même quantité
d'énergie primaire qui est consommé dans
les bâtiments pour les bâtiments
résidentiels et tertiaires tous
confondus pour le chauffage et pour
l'électricité donc l'électricité c'est
un poste de consommation très important
et bord d'un bâtiment de but
équi pe gamme en bureautique la
consommation électrique par mètre carré
est bien supérieure à la consommation de
chauffage par mètre carré
donc là la consommation électrique et ça
c avec le facteur d'éviction français
donc dans avec dans un aux états unis
par exemple la barre de gauche serait
significativement supérieur les
déplacements de personnes va vous allez
trouver les déplacements domicile
travail
mais là en l'occurrence il s'agissait
d'un établissement situé dans paris donc
ça c'était pas grand chose et puis comme
chacun sait les cadres bancaires
extrêmement bien payée ont de quoi
prendre l'avion à tire larigot
donc ces gens là prenait de manière
significative l'avion et je vous
rappelle encore une fois que l'alliance
est un réservoir de kérosène volant donc
ça engendre des émissions qui sont pas
du tout négligeable dans cette affaire
ensuite une banque est agréé très gros
acheteurs de services pour ceux d'entre
vous qui s'intéressent un tout petit peu
à l'informatique parce que
éventuellement vous envisagez d'en faire
votre métier vous savez peut-être que le
premier débouché des sociétés de conseil
en informatique c'est les banques
1 donc l'argent revient à ce que disait
tout à l'heure une société une ss2i
c'est un endroit où là aussi vous
chauffer les gens vouloir acheter des
ordinateurs qui du reste bien trop
performant pour ce qu'ils en font et
c'est donc vous avez des émissions qui
sont associées au fait de développer des
cols du code logiciel voilà et ses
émissions vous allez retrouver dans les
services qui sont achetés par la banque
vous allez aussi trouver du papier dans
votre banque
là c'était pas une banque de détail donc
en l'occurrence ils sont pas des relevés
de compte d'une manière face à ça
s'apaise pas à si long que ça contient
des beaucoup de services et enfin
pleinement la banque n'est pas une
activité qui s'exerce en télétravail
donc vous construisez des bleus par
ailleurs vous avez besoin d'informatique
sur place les salles informatiques des
banques comme vous le savez même si elle
sous traite une partie de cette activité
c'est aussi quelque chose qui peut
représenter
des montants enfin qui peut qui y
présentait dès maintenant assez
important et vous allez retrouver donc
ici la fabrication à la fois des locaux
occupés et de l'informatique utiliser le
résultat des courses c'est que s'ils
veulent ramener les émissions de cette
banque
et là je ne parle même pas des prêts aux
salariés qui y travaillent
et bien vous allez arriver à la
conclusion que pour que vous ayez un
emploi dans cette danse là il fait
émettre quelque chose qui veut 2 à 4
fois les émissions annuelles d'un
français ordinaire un à l'arrière c'est
pas des émissions qui sont directement
le fait du salarié mais un travail dans
ce genre d'endroit dépens on va dire des
émissions dépend d'un volume d'émission
pardon qui peut représenter plusieurs
fois les émissions annuelles d'un
français
donc l'idée que le tertiaire n'est pas
considérée n'est pas concernée par don
par la contrainte un qui les ont
contraintes
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique et l'approvisionnement en
énergie fossile est une idée qui fait ou
sortir de la tête
le tertiaire est parfaitement concernés
par cette contrainte
du reste vous voyez bien que là c'est
une investigation qui a été fait
or près si vous prêtez à des activités
qui vont tout faire faillite les unes
derrière les autres dans un monde dans
lequel le prix de l'énergie se met à
augmenter de manière très forte
eh bien vous voyez que c'est difficile
de garder des activités prospère comme
banques
sur un autre registre c'est ce qu' un
certain nombre d'établissements
financiers sont en train de constater
aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on appelle la
crise du subprime
on vous avait des défauts de paiement en
pagaille des gens à qui vous avez prêté
de l'argent et bien le changement
climatique et une augmentation du prix
de l'énergie de manière erratique
pourrait donner lieu à exactement la
même chose c'est-à-dire une série de
faillites bancaires en cascade
tout simplement parce que les gens à qui
on l'apprêté sont soumis à la contrainte
de manière forte et cette contrainte se
matérialisent de manière trop soudaine
pour qu'on puisse y adapter un jeu
reprendra sur des exemples après la
pause essayer d'être à l'heure parce que
je le serai